bu Selamünaleyküm Hoş geldiniz
dinlediğimizi Anladım köşesinde ben
varım aşkım şimdi bazı sorular soracağım
size Akçakale Belediyesi nin aylık bebek
bezi
bu tüketimi kaç bindir
270.000 bilemediniz doğru mu abi 170.000
Bir dahakine bonusla 171 170 bin böyle
vurgula tam hakkında kalmıyor çok havalı
tedex gerçekten arayıp tebrik eden
arkadaşlarımız da tek toksa
çıkıyormuşsun diye
hiç bozmadım Evet ya TED Talks yerden
kavurur ya amca ben Counter Strike var
bitti yok ama not that much
mi Evet 295 lira olduğunu öğrendim
iletin
ben onu dediklerinde Ben dedim ben
gelmem senden almayacağız dediler yemin
ettirdim sime Ekmek Kur'an çarpsın
dedikten sonra gelme kararı aldım Size
gerçekten saygı duyuyorum Çünkü 295
liraya Ben izleyeceğim bir şey vermem
var yani o parayı verdiysen Somut bir
şey almam lazım
o eve götürebileceğim ağırlığı olan bir
şey yani Tamam şimdi 95 lira verdim ve
yol ay Benlik bir şey değil ben sende
sanatları ile ilgilendi olarak bu konuya
bakayım şöyle 3 arkadaşlık gösteri
yaptık ve k&m de gösterin fiyatını
belirlemek için istişare yaptık kendi
aramızda bir tanesi dedi ki 30 lira
olsun
Sen benden şu ben o paraya duble
İskender yerim
bu hak verdiler yani
ama biz duble İskender etmeyiz güldürür
ama durmayız yani
o kendi aralarında biraz düşünmediler 25
olsun dedim
ne yok
11.30 buçuk İskender yerim
Bu bir sessizlik oldu kendi aralarında
Gene biraz olayım ithalat ilerde ler 20
olsun dedim İskender yerim
Sen oradan gerildi
bu gerçek bir sessizlik var Ben gösterme
aklımı kaçırıyorum negotiation Devrent
pazarlık modundayım
o en son dediler ki 15 olsun
Ben dedim 5 da koyar
bu daha dediler bu aç Bunun karnını
doyuralım ki fiyatı netleştirebilirim
bu sağolsunlar tavuk döner ısmarla 10
liraya ya hadi onu da koysan
bu erken camda açmış Ama benden açınca
gördüm Kadıköy'de çocuğu bir beni
çevirdi inanılmaz kilolu Yani biraz
yuvarlanıyor biraz iki adım atıyor gene
yuvarlayın falan abicim Beni yanlış
anlama dedi senden para istemiyorum bana
yemek ısmarla
şu an dedim bu kadarsın artık para
istemedim vakti gelmemiş mi Ha Doymuş su
Gel seni tok olduğunu ben görebiliyorum
Ha bir de soda iç farklı bir şey dene
Evet Ee bu eski televizyonda yapmıştım
bunun xiyu belirtisini denedim şimdi
rezilyans olarak
O espri gayet Sürdürülebilir geldi ilk
defa anlattım ikinci kez güzel belki
seyirci yenilenebilir Onu bilmiyorum Çok
güzel bir gece Right here Right Now
biraz iddialı bir şey bana göre bütün
sloganlar iddia alamadığı trigono fazla
iddialı şimdi Right Arrow key Yani
buraya olur şunu olur ha farketmez
dışarı Back Yarın okey veremiyoruz
beraber ama Nasıl yani
var ya bir otur ya abi öpüyor otur abi
konuşalım bir dakika yani çıkacağım
dakika belli olmasa ben bunu ilelebet
erteledim ya Bir dakika abi ya ayak şey
yapayım sen tablosudur ayak yapma yani
bu inanılmaz üşengeç bir insanım
babamdan geçtiğini tespit ettim
şimdilerde babama ne yapıyorsun dediği
zaman şöyle bir cevap veriyor sıklıkla
duruyor
var yani var olmak Onun için yeterli bir
eylem
Bu bir hacmin var yalan daha ne yani
boşlukta yer kaplıyor mu Ne yapayım Daha
ne yapayım yani
var ama Right Now gerçekten önemli yaş
geçiyor Geçenlerde Basket oynarken
çocuklardan biri bana Kaç yaşındasın
dedi
Evet şu Hazin cevabı verdim Kaç
gösteriyorum
Ama artık artık bir şeyler yapmanın
vakti geliyor ama her telefonda bir
yaştan sonra hepten yani toplumda seni
bir şey yapıştıramıyor bazı programlar
var Bunu nasıl Hayattasın olması lazım
adı
Op.Dr ama Anadolu'yu geziyor köyleri ve
o Yaşına rağmen ölmemiş yaşlılarla
röportajı bir nasıl ölmedin değil yani
konusu o hakkı amca tam 95 yaşında ve
hala odun kırıyor yanak kaldı odun
kırıyor dut atak ve arkada karısıyla
konuştuğunu hakkında konuşma tek kişilik
olduğu kabak gerçekten konuşma hakkı
amca karısıyla geziyorlar işte evi
geziyorlar karıştı gidici yırtan otuyla
yaşam olsun kaynatın üşürüm diyor bir
formüller var teyzenin Hakkı amcanın
arkadan sadece sesi geliyor ha o onu
kalp gitmiyor yani o stres gelir
saklanınca öldü yani köy biliyor yani
hakkımda öldü geçen bir yaşlı bana sordu
saat tam olarak kaç dedi yani yaşlı
derken yaşı tam kestiremiyorum çünkü
hani 85 değilim ama yani 70t 100 arası
gibi bi her 88rs gös
Bu parçada 85 demezsin yani
Bu ortama 85
o dedi ki saat tam olarak kaç tam olarak
sadece söyledim
var ama içinde şunu düşündüm yani ne
yapacaksın
E tamam zaten ne yapacaksın ya ya gündüz
ya işte daha uyuma yani şey sağol Hava
kararınca uyu aydınlanacak ezan okununca
namazını kıl bunlar
mı bunlar
daha sonra ilaç ilaç saati olabilir
yaşlarına genifique yaşından altı Hocama
saygılar buradan yola çıkarak şu düşün
yaşlılık Gerçekten inanılmaz Heyecanlı
bir oyun gibi yani Mesela Superman
ediyorsanız bütün canlıları bitmiş tek
canın kalmış tamam mı mı Her sabah
uyanıyorsun ve tek amacın akşama kadar
ölmemek ilacını kaçırırsan game over ha
düşmem lazım düş merdivenden şöyle
iniyorsun ki düşersen game over yani
reset de yok resetteki âlem yani mi
eşhedü enla Refet yani
O çok zor yaşlılık çok önemli konular
vardı Gerçekten bilmiyorum hepsi aynı
öneme sahip mi Çünkü bir tarafta robotik
var robot yapıp dünyaya meydan okuyan
gençler falan var Boeing ekranı
tasarlayan Bir Var Bir tarafta da 20
tane kadınla yemek yaptırdım turistlere
sattığı diyen o da önemli O da önemli
yani herkes robot yapsak Yemeği kim
yapacak tabi mutfak robotu değilse o da
yapılabilir da sıkıntı bu çok önemli
robotik gerçekten önemli ama ben bilgi
sevmez tuttum yapay zekayı bir türlü
hazmedemedim
Ama gerçekten seviyorum Gel gerçek zeka
köreltiyor gibi geliyor bana birkaç kere
ya Navigasyona sorarken tabelayı
kaçırdığım oldu apartman kadar
İstanbul'a gideceğim döneceğim nereden
döneceğim bir geri zekalı ya tarif eder
gibi anlatıyor hafifçe sağdan yani Sen
sağa dön desem tarla gidecek halim yok
ya hafifçe sağdan kime yarısı geliyorsun
O çok bilmiş
o geri zekalı araştıralım sana bir
çamaşır makinesi reklamı vardı Yapay
Zeka sertmiş adamın karısı Start ile
çıkıyor adam da evde bir parti verir
çamaşır masa örtüsünde bir şeyler
dökülüyor masaüstüne eline alıyor
birinde masa örtüsü birinde şey deterjan
çamaşır makinesi karşıdaki bir şey
yapıyor
abone ol
O ne lan
bu deterjanı deterjan gözüne koyacaksın
Masa örtüsünü yani masaüstü zaten
deterjan gözüne sığmaz yani ev
kadınların hedefledik şöyle bir sloganlı
silme Sen de bir gerizekalıyla evlisiniz
korkmayız biz varız gibi bir şey ya
bu hazmedemiyorum yapay zekaya ya
bilgisayarı kapat dediğimde Emin misin
diye sorduğunda bile ayarladım sana ne
Belki emin değilim Belki içimde Ukde
kalacak Her Gece boyunca uyuyamayacağım
Şimdi kapatmayalım diyeceğim belki ama
sen kafan sana ne emin miyim değil miyim
ya Yapay Zeka
Her insan gibi düşünen bilgisayar mış
yani bana kaybettiğim insanlığımı
hatırlatacak Ya ben film izlerken
arkadan millet aç aç Sabahtan beri filmi
izliyorsun Ben de aç aç bunu mu yapacak
ya benim insanlığımı test ediyor ya Ya
ben üç kere Şifremi yanlış değilsem
Bulanık bir yazı orada Şehirde İnsan
mısın sen insan mısın lan Lan Bulanık
yazı çözmeye mi insan olacaksın sor bana
komşu masken Tok yatıyor muyum
bu Bakkalda mı alıyorum yoğurdu gidip
süpermarketten mi alıyorum Küçük esnafa
destek oluyor mu olmuyor mu soru sor
ve yapay zeka biliyor rağbet görüyor
beğenmek zor buradaki konuşmacıların
hepside
var ya bu ülkede beğenmek yapacağız Hani
orkestra şefi çöplerden getiren gelen
abi çöplerin şeylerden bir orkestra şey
yapmış ya o Onun için hep İngiltere'de
kolay burada yapsan Yani bu alkış
almazdı Yani Türkiye'de yapsan yani Sen
ne yapıyorsun dedim Şu çöpü bir bırak ya
Sen ne yapıyorsun ya şeysin Adam ol az
biraz
bu ne gecesi çöpün içinde yani çok zor
beğeniyoruz ya Facebook'ta beğen tuşuna
en az tıklanan 3. ülkemiz Türkiye
bu bölümü veriyor bunu attım kimse
itiraz etmediğine göre burada bilgili
insan Demek ki olabilir Bir zor
beğeniyorsanız vallahi zor beğenir Yani
bu ülkede darbe oldu darbe kimse darbeyi
beğenmedi
bu Ümit Abim olur ya tamam Ha neredeyiz
sabah yapacağız sabah Tamam Güneş
doğmaya yakın yani ve ağırdır ve kuşluk
vaktinde B herkesin müzikli var Herkes
bir darbe bilgisini çekilen motoru musun
Yani yavrum darbeyi akşam da hızlı
yazacağım diye teyze falan var ya ya Sağ
olun teşekkürler